today I'm here I'm here with tide i'm
here with pure clean they launched a
whole new product it's their first
bio-based products oh all the people
that love tide and kind of like trusted
in the laundry room they can now buy a
bio-based version and i'm involved today
because we're also here with worldwide
life fund and we're doing a special
internship with canadians because this
is the canadian launch of pure clean and
so pure clean will donate a dollar per
tweet if you tweet out pure clean and
count with nature yes and the hashtag
yeah and so basically up to like a
hundred thousand dollars all months so
long with Movember all this initiative
it's really easy and basically you can
talk about how you everyday ways you can
help help the environment so for me I
Drive a hybrid car I love it in Toronto
you know you're idling all the time I
literally fill up my tank like once a
month also if I'm purging or doing
spring cleaning or something like that I
try to donate items rather than throw
them out I try to get like Habitat for
Humanity to come pick up like furniture
or even fixtures like you don't doesn't
have to go to the landfill there wit and
recycling electronics yep all those
things so just little ways we can all
help and I grew up housekeeping I grew
up as a chambermaid and I know how
important like people's trusted products
are and that shift you know towards
buying like a more eco-friendly product
is not always easy for all people they
sometimes have hesitations like I grew
up in the laundry room watching my mom
clean you know and and do laundry and so
I kind of understand i also wrote songs
while i clean rooms yeah i did and a lot
of my new album a lot of the songs I
wrote while cleaning my own house have
been clean my house the last couple
years in doing my laundry yeah totally
because it's this meditative place I go
to and then I stop and a song comes to
mean I sit at the piano or the guitar so
it's really something I take pride in um
so anyway yeah all these exciting
reasons to be here today so you always
been an activist I guess you can say you
could say I grew up in bc so i grew up
in vancouver island it's a beautiful
place its trees oceans my father would
take us for long walks along the ocean
side and just kind of like that whole
reverence you know her nature was
definitely instilled in us and I think
that's why now it's oh I'm waist
conscious out of it I'm always kind of
thinking okay how is this impacting the
bigger picture I'm also
an ambassador for free the children and
I think even the work that they do
specifically on my travels to Kenya I've
seen how it's all about sustainability
it's all about okay how will this affect
the next generation on the next
generation so I think a large brand like
time making a step like this is pretty
huge and i think it's it's a it's a fun
opportunity able to talk about all these
things but i don't always talk about
right like not everybody knows like a
clean my house like i do my laundry you
know like it's it's the good stuff right
here's did you do that for actually 10
10 years yeah I started with 12 till
about 18 yeah thank you I forget you as
as I get older in life we're not getting
any younger and we're having kids now
Adam haha yeah thinking about what world
we're gonna aren't you aren't you it's
not everybody's wise I think we're just
more so now we're learning more aren't
we we're learning where we're more
conscious and so everybody's thinking
about this um I have a 13 year old
daughter same same thing you're
wondering what am i teaching your how am
I living by example what am I modeling
and we're not perfect yet I mean we're
all just trying our best you know
demands you do teacher good ways of you
know keeping the environment clean yeah
it's a constant theme you know I mean
cuz I think kids need reminders and for
something as simple as recycling you
might be like oh actually that's compost
and recycling or garbage or maybe I
actually one of her chores at home is
taking out the garbage and recycling so
maybe that also is getting that
installed in her um but cat simple
things like maybe also trying to instill
11 nature today we've been planting
seeds because we're with them we're with
a brother nature we're with brother
nature a trick works in Toronto and it's
a great green space it's got such great
energy and we're planting on milkweed
seeds for the greenhouse excellent so
yeah all of these things